NO. NO. YES.
>> [laughter]
>> AMY DID MYRON. MYRON, YOU GOOD, MAN?
WHAT?
>> RIGHT. And now you want to defend me.
I'm sick
>> No way. Amy Dangerfield, Myron. Amy
Dangerfield.
>> No. Oh, no. I don't even regret my
charges or convictions. I've made
mistakes. I learn from them. Sometimes I
don't.
>> [music]
>> I'm being told that Amy that Zena's
crashing out on Amy Dangerfield. So, I
think we're going to go straight into
drama.
Amy Dangerfield got kind of exposed on
this Brilliam account. Relaify HQ,
that's the one. And Amy Dangerfield got
exposed. And she got exposed. I think it
was the Darius Zena clip, right? Where
she's making out with Zena in front of
Darius and Relaigh. That got put in
there. And everybody
everybody was like making fun of her and
she did a stream about it and said, "Oh,
yeah. It's like I have a checkered past
and all this [__] right?" And yes, it
recently blew up because of the Lauren
DeLaguana interview. Either way, it's
like kind of blowing up now. And yeah,
she's crazy. Dude, what a vibe.
Immediately I'm immediately sitting here
like what a vibe. The vibe is
incredible.
The vibe is incredible immediately.
Let's go.
Zena's crashing out.
I don't even know how to start this
because unfortu- Okay, unfortunately I'm
pissed off cuz I was at work. I was
making some cash, making some money.
After I do that, tell me why I get on
the internet and people are tagging me
and all this [__]
about this Amy Dangerfield stuff. And
apparently there's a clip of Sneako
saying, you know, it's a matrix attack.
And I'm like,
>> [laughter]
>> "What is this?" So, I click a few things
and I see that people are calling me a
liar. Okay, let's check it out.
>> many [__] times I've been called a
liar and then I have to pull up
receipts.
I open my Twitter and it's this
First of all, I said this what, 2 years
2 or 3 years ago?
Or maybe it was 2 years ago. Maybe it
was 1 year ago. I I know when the [__] I
first exposed it. Yes, we Amy
Dangerfield.
There's actually way more than just
that. But okay, now I'm posting
screenshots where I have to
prove that once again, Sneako lied
because what does Sneako do but always
lie and then get exposed and then say
it's a matrix attack.
This was in 2023. I have the receipts
with the date and the time. I have
videos of us. No, I do not have videos
of us. No revenge at all. When I say I
have videos, Okay, Zena.
>> out. It's us dancing. It's us getting
drunk together. This was 2023. I don't
give a [__] if Sneako said it was cap
because there's text conversations not
just between me and Amy. There's text
conversations between me and Sneako
where he's asking me to convince Amy to
have a threesome. I have all of it.
Anyway,
and I'm just so tired of this whole
thing of oh, I'm I'm lying as if I don't
have all the receipts every single time
where we're having these conversations.
Mind you, it's not a bad thing that
Sneako
or that I helped him get multiple
threesomes when we were dating. Yeah,
I'm a down ass [__]
That was my You know, he says he wants
to [__] with me. I'm going to tell I'll
convince the [__] don't want to [__]
him. Obviously, I'm going to convince
the girl
Zena is awesome. to [__] So she did
because she likes me. As you guys can
see when we're
an unmedicated manic episode, right? No.
Zena is Zena is perfectly capable of
doing this.
Like totally fine. Like totally on the
level.
I think Zena Zena is really People don't
understand that Zena is like a fantastic
streamer. But like when she's on the
level, she's a fantastic streamer. She
does crash out sometimes, but just her
by herself like totally leveled off,
totally fine, she's incredibly
entertaining. hanging out with Darius
after me and Sneako break up, Amy and I
continued to make out and enjoy, you
know,
type things together because love me,
I'm
I love females. I love women. So, yeah,
I like to get Me and Sneako had probably
like four or five threesomes. And
there's other women that are now married
and in relationships that, you know, we
were trashing the [__] out in the
bedroom that are red pill conservatives
that are lying to their husbands
as if they're these tradwives. And it's
like
I don't know if Amy's doing that, to be
honest with you. Like I'm I'm pretty
sure Amy was like, "Nah, I I had a
past." I Did she not? I thought she did
a stream was like, "Yeah, I'm only
Christian now. I like have a pretty
checkered past."
If I like a guy and I'm with him for a
while and he's cute, okay, I'm not
ashamed of it. Let me finish talking cuz
I don't even need to go all the way in
on this again because
that's what I was saying. Where am I? I
don't even know where the [__] I'm at.
They're grifting this whole like Okay,
what happened is why I first ever said
anything about the threesome with Amy
was because she snaked Destiny. When
Destiny was putting her on, helping her
even get out in the industry in the
first place. The whole coper red pill
scene she wanted to get in. Destiny was
putting her on. And she just randomly
started snaking him when number one, oh,
over Pixie, when she didn't even like
Pixie. They talked [__] about each
other. They didn't even like each other.
She wanted to move the [__] away from
them. And she didn't like Lauren either.
They were all beefing secretly. They
were all beefing with each other
secretly. I have all those messages they
were telling me about it. Oh, they hate
each other. Da da da. These were catty
ass hoes. They weren't friends. They
were talking about who's dirty, who
leaves the apartment a mess cuz they all
lived together at one point. Now you
coming for my friend? I'mma put your
business out there because you married
that and you've been lying to that and
let me tell you when me and Sneako
[__] this hoe, it was only one week
after her and her boyfriend had broken
up.
One week, but you're this trad
conservative woman? You talk about women
on OnlyFans? You couldn't even wait two
months? At least I wait two, three
months before I [__] on some new
You didn't give your a break, hoe. And
on top of that, before me and Sneako
[__] her,
at this point I'll put everybody out
there. I owe nothing to none of these
people. Myron, Fresh, all these people
that told me to be quiet when me and
Sneako first broke up and they wanted to
defend Sneako and Osina don't expose
this. Osina don't do this. It's bad.
It's bad. Blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah. Now Fresh and Sneako
aren't friends and Fresh is Oh yeah,
Zena was right. Blah blah blah blah
blah. I don't owe Myron loyalty. I don't
owe Fresh loyalty. I don't owe none of
these loyalty. I'm not under any NDA.
Guess what?
I have receipts on all these on the baby
jewelry and I'm tired of defending this
god damn for lying and then when they're
mad it's By the way, Zena was right. Oh
oh now I was right because you guys are
beefing. Now I was right and now you
want to defend me. I'm sick of that.
But anyway,
before me and Sneako even
Amy,
she had just not two days prior
a different man.
And I could say who it is. I could
actually just say who it is and I have
receipts of that as well. Wait. What?
>> Right and now you want to defend me. I'm
sick of that.
>> But anyway,
before me and Sneako even
Amy,
she had just not two days prior
a different man.
And I could say who it is. I could
actually just say Oh, it's just a
totally different guy. Okay. Come on.
START GET SAUSNICK IN THE MIX. THROW A
GRENADE at him, Sausnick. I'll say I'm
red pill because I agree with a lot of
red pill stuff. But is it red pill about
being honest?
I'm not saying I'm red pill because I'm
conservative or you know, I'm not a hoe.
I don't need to be married to these
If I like a guy and the vibe is right
and I want to [__] him, I'm a grown ass
woman. I will [__] him and I don't give
a [__] if the internet calls me a hoe. I
know what I'm doing with my
Every man that wants to [__] me doesn't
get to [__] me. I choose who to [__]
gets to [__] this okay? And yeah, sure.
Right now it's 17. Cool. By the end of
this year it might be 20. Honey, it
might be 30. If I find attractive men
and I want to [__] them, I will the [__]
out of them because I can. It's that
simple. If you have to sit here and lie
and grift and pretend to be this holier
than thou virtuous person, why are you
having sex in the first place? Maybe
don't do it if you feel shame. You
should never do something in life that
you regret and feel shame for. I've made
some dumb decisions. I don't regret
them. They are life lessons. I don't
regret a god damn thing. I don't regret
Um
you totally felt regret for all of this
at least.
Definitely that I've remembered. You
can't just flip your principles to
nothing matters and go, "Well, actually
you should never do anything if it gives
you shame."
Sounds like you're sort of post hoc
rationalizing a principle that you never
actually had.
>> Right, a relationship? Anyway, I don't
regret my body. I don't regret hell. I
don't even regret my charges
or convictions. I've made mistakes. I
learn from them. I You should regret
those, actually. You should You should
regret those. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Sometimes I don't. And I need to make
that mistake Dude, no way.
>> I don't even regret my charges
or convictions. I've made mistakes. I
learn from them. Sometimes I don't.
I don't feel bad about them, but I learn
from them. But sometimes I also don't
learn from them. Fantastic stuff.
>> And I need to make that mistake two
three more times. But
guess what? They're life lessons. I
don't regret I don't feel shame for I'm
not embarrassed by I tell the world my
business because ain't nobody going to
expose me.
See, that's not a way to live. You
You're just describing like a permission
structure to be a terrible human being.
But you know what?
It is funny, so we let it go. told you
that? Oh, that's right. I did. The If I
get a yeast infection tomorrow, I'll go
on there and I'll be like, "Damn, guys,
I got a yeast infection." If I catch
STD, we're going to talk about it. I'll
be like, "Guys, I got a STD from this
I'm going
I will be telling you because I'm an
open book and I don't give a [__]
Um but these people that care so much
about what other people think, so they
sit there lying and grifting and doing
all this
and then it comes out. Cap, hold on.
Let me pull this up. Okay, this one's
not the blurred one. I'm sorry. Why are
we having this conversation? Why are we
Say Murthy, "Haha, sounds good. I'll
text him back." Now. Yeah, thanks. Don't
tell me to go or blank. Oh.
I could see this being Myron, right? An
N here potentially.
Uh I don't know though. I'm never going
to tell anyone in my entire life. Okay.
Well, having this conversation. And this
was May of 2023. 2023, he made a whole
He made a whole video about it. You can
Google it. You can Google it. There's
facts, there's tweets, there's
everything. He was already a Muslim by
the time me and Sneako were dating,
okay?
Um yeah, I said don't tell him you
Sneako or blank. There's another person
she
I'm never going to tell anyone in my
entire life. Did you tell your husband?
Did you tell your husband? And then this
is just about me being like he thinks
you're bi because you me. He admitted
that I you on stream and I'm like no.
So my thing is it's just you're not this
trad life.
>> Everyone knew that one though. Come on
man. Everyone knew that one though. Come
on man. Everyone knew that one though.
Come on man. Everyone knew that one
though. Come on man. Everyone knew that
one though. Come on man. Everyone knew
that one though. Come on man. Everyone
knew that one though. Come on man.
Everyone knew that one though. Come on
man. Everyone knew that one though. Come
on man. Everyone knew that one though.
Come on man.
Everyone knew that one though. Come on
man.
You had a on a that was that was five
years younger than you and get pregnant
because he had money so that you could
be a trad wife because you was getting
treats out in these streets. All these
conservative women Carley thinks was a
in the past too. She was
big black
>> [laughter]
>> We all knew this one though. This isn't
new. We all knew this one.
It's just she's not that attractive so
she couldn't be that big of a hoe. You
know what I'm saying? Isabella
She's not ugly. Obviously she was at
these college parties in all these
pictures in lingerie going to Diddy
parties looking like, you know, hoe.
Hoe. Amy, hoe. That four people after
her breakup. Four. Since I met her on
Fresh and Fit, four. No.
No. Yes.
>> [laughter]
>> Dude, Zena is so funny man.
God, why can't she just be a good person
and keep the content like together for
two seconds?
No. No. Yes.
Hoe. That four people after her breakup.
Four. Since I met her on Fresh and Fit,
four. No. No. Yes. Four.
But she's a trad wife. And they were
only broken up for a week. On top of
that, here's another juicy thing. One of
them that she
>> Oh,
wait, hold on. That makes it Wait, four
Wait, what?
Four dudes in a week. Okay, that's a
That changes everything. It's like four
is not that many in a week. Oh.
That's a couple. That's a couple.
>> She brought her current husband around.
Does he know they were because
why are you hanging around and you with
your husband?
Are you a cuck?
Are you a Are you aware that that they
were
If you are aware and you're like, you
know what, it's cool, it's business.
Okay, cool, whatever. Do you. If you
weren't aware, then she's a dirty,
disgusting because that's nasty. Because
if you and your husband are in these
spaces, you're on So, signal the Ice
Poseidon. Is it Harris talking Kimmi
subtly right here? Okay, okay. Hey, Ice
doesn't always take Kimmi's side.
Listen.
>> And you're in this industry, especially
red pill, where men and women are
targeted the most and you know, they
have to uphold themselves the most, why
the are you bringing your husband around
you were
And also not having him aware so that
the internet can call him a and they can
smash on him. You now represent your
husband and you look like a fool, so now
your husband looks like a fool. Like
what?
That's your husband. If I'm with a man,
I mean, all my boyfriends know everyone
I because I tell them I'll be like, oh,
I pumped her, I this guy did her. I'll
tell them because that's what you're
supposed to do. Yeah, they hold it
against me when we break up like, her,
she was this. Okay, whatever. At least
you knew. At least you didn't get
blindsided. At least I didn't bring you
around and I was
and have you clap hands with him and
hang out. Meanwhile, that like, damn, I
was I had your girl bent over backwards.
I was on her back raw and you're
marrying that.
You getting here clowned. Your husband's
getting clowned because you lied. That's
weird. But you're a tradwife. I just I
just don't understand the grift of like
I know I know red pill gets you like
notoriety, whatever the [__] it's
called, but why grift? You could easily
just be honest and be like, yeah, you
know, I had this past and I feel like
red pill actually changed my mind and I
feel like I wish I would have
Is this about Isabella or Amy? It's
about everyone, okay? It's about
Isabella, it's about Amy, it's about
everybody, all right?
>> sooner because I would have been a
different person. Just let Zena cook,
man.
>> you I don't know why Zena's going off. I
think Zena just, you know, she felt like
she wanted to leak some stuff.
Hopefully, she gets in a flow and just
starts leaking a bunch of other [__]
too. That's what I'm here for. I'm
hoping that Zena will get into a flow of
like leaking [__] on Amy Dangerfield and
then just go like, "Also, you, you, you,
you, you." Cuz that tends to be what
happens.
>> happening, [__] On top of that, you
didn't stop after me and Nico you were
still coming around. You was about to
[__] me and Darius. She just didn't
really like Darius and then I was
getting to know him and I was like,
"Yeah, no, I don't want to give this man
a threesome and like you know, we're
just getting together." Like, "No, he
didn't earn that yet." But as you guys
can see from those clips, we're
obviously making the [__] out full Oh,
dude.
>> wonton action. She was very comfortable
because and and also, I mean, her [__]
was pretty. It is pink. It tasted nice.
It was clean. It wasn't nasty. She
didn't stink. None of that. It It was
nice. Like, I'm not one of those I don't
have to sit here and lie be like, "Oh,
she had a drink that stank dirty dirty
This is very weird now. Thank you, Zena.
She's doing She's doing her live forever
guy impression, okay? Actually, her
microbiome was top 1% of all the
If you If you guys are interested to
know.
>> Does she got a cute Yes, the [__] was
nice. But back to what I was saying.
No! [__] this
And then going on the internet, going on
all these podcasts, bringing him around
men you were already
It just It just makes it easier to [__]
on you people. Like, it just makes it
easier to [__] on you. And the sad part
is is when you're getting mugged and
[__] on by an OnlyFans witch,
that makes it worse. It's like, "Damn,
so that's This is who's carrying Red
Pill? This is what the Groypers were all
championing or championing? Oh my god!
Oh my god! Conservative white woman."
She's a
I hate to break it to you, Zena. The
Groypers assume all of the all of like
the right-wing tradwives who are who
have a social media presence, they
assume they're all
That's like the assumption until proven
otherwise. As in, yes, you need to prove
the negative. We will just call you a
forever, actually. There is no winning.
There's literally no winning. You are a
as soon as you enter those spaces. And
then if you die without ever being
exposed as a then they're like,
well, you know, exception proves the
rule. That's how it works, man.
>> Nothing wrong with it. It's the only
thing wrong with the lying part.
I don't even know what a
I like Nick Fuentes, he's funny. That's
about it. I don't really give a about
any of it, but it is what it is.
Oh, there's a A ho is a ho. Y'all call
it
I don't really call it a but that's what
you guys will label any woman that isn't
a virgin is a
So, that's why we're saying that. Is she
And to be honest, because she lied, I
feel like there's a lot more going on
than even I know. Because she's clearly
lying. Like what the I tell you who I I
genuinely don't give a
It's not a flex.
Sneako was hot. Yeah, I was him for a
while. Okay? He was hot. I liked it.
There's a couple people that I clearly
was very attracted to and I was like,
yeah, let me bag that. And I bagged it.
Okay, I might have a male mentality in a
female's body, but I like it. So, yeah,
it's a flex for me. Y'all
>> You're amazing. Thank you for this.
Um yeah, I'm a trumper. I'm not red
pill. Yeah, if I like somebody like a
celebrity and I'm like, you know, I want
that and I get it, it's a flex for me. I
don't give a Call me a then baby, I'm a
Call me Marilyn Monroe cuz she was a
too. And you know what? This is totally
unscripted, by the way. Zena can just
rant like this for like hours.
Straight up hours. She can rant like
this without taking a single breath or
pausing at all. Just like infinite. It's
it's infinite. It will come out forever.
That's got her places, so I'm going to
start getting my place. Anyways, back to
what I was saying.
I just think it's like, I don't know,
man. It's just
it's totally insane.
It's totally insane. And And the only
reason I'm so offended is, why the would
you try to come for me and call me a
liar knowing I got the receipts?
I don't just talk out my ass. Wait, did
Amy call her a liar? I didn't see that.
Did Amy Dangerfield come out and say
Zena was wrong on this?
Did she come out and say like, oh,
actually Zena's just making this up or
somebody's just making this up?
And not have proof. I feel like that
almost certainly didn't happen. I feel
like maybe at best, you might have
gotten a tweet like this is wrong or
something.
Yeah, yeah, I feel like
I feel like Zena takes it as so if she
if you say that something she knows is
true is false, even if you're calling
somebody else a liar, I think I feel
like sometimes Zena is just like, oh, I
got you. I I'll get you right now, okay?
I'll prove that this is Sneako did? Oh.
Oh, well, Sneako did? Uh-oh.
Oh.
Unlucky. Expose all the grifters?
You know what? I have files on these
people. And the reason I have files now
is I heard some [__] when Ice Poseidon
said he had files on everybody,
I got inspired. I was like, yo, this guy
is actually psychotic.
Maniacal? Is that what it's called?
Maniacal? I like
I was kind of
on Ice Poseidon until I found out he was
a total psychopath, and then I was like,
dude, that's awesome.
>> And I was just like, but he's very
smart. Him and Kimmy are very smart
people. And when I hear him talk about
the files he has on people in the
confidence, I'm like,
you know what? Boom. So, what did I
start doing? Archiving. I've made my own
files on people. Especially these red
pill grifters, okay? So, I have the
files, too. Um
Marilyn died at 36, near your age. Cool,
I can die at 36. I'll
Six more years, cool. I'll be out of
this. Thank you. World's going to [__]
anyway. We got virgin roipers running
around here champagning.
Does she think when people say
champagning, they mean champagning?
Champagning? They're champagning a
Getting married to people, bringing them
around. They was
Yeah, bro, that's fine.
How you attract, but ain't red pill? I'm
not red pill because I don't agree that
um
you know, men can [__] anyone and women
need to be virgins. I I
I don't agree. I think people should
What's happening? Uh Zena has exposed
that Amy Dangerfield was a
bit promiscuous after her previous
breakup, and that she had a threesome
with Amy Dangerfield and Sneako. Uh
maybe more than one. And she said no,
she said more than one threesome with
with Amy Dangerfield before. That's what
it is.
>> Should do whatever the people want to
do. Because I think Sneako called her a
liar. She said she said Amy, but did she
say Virgil? I think she said Virgil.
>> bringing them around cuz they was
Yeah, bro. That's fine.
How you a Trump but ain't red-pilled?
I'm not red-pilled because I don't agree
that um
you know, men can anyone and women need
to be virginal. I I don't act Virginal.
Virginal.
>> I think people should do whatever the
people want to do, but be safe about it,
be honest about it, and harm none. Um
that's it. So I I don't know. I don't
know what what you want to call that,
but like generally, I don't think I need
to rush and get married and have babies.
That's not what's on my mind. I like
making money. And yeah, like I'm talking
to someone. Sometimes I talk to two
people. Um and if I decide, you know
what? It's going well, I might crack.
Then I might crack. I don't want to be
confined to this oh, I'm loyal to this
person because I'm committed to them,
but now this hot attractive person who
might be my dream guy is suddenly
hitting me up like, "Hey, we haven't
talked in a while. Like I really like
you. Can I see you?" So yeah, my dumb
ass ignored the man of my dreams.
Darius. And then after that, I ended up
with
a some random young dude just because he
had young and I was like, "You know
what? He easy. He'll let me do whatever
I want. I can get all my kinks out. I
can literally run this
in the bedroom." So yeah, okay guys.
Y'all want to call me a groomer? Then
call me a groomer. I had a young
It was decent. I could whenever I
wanted. He did whatever I wanted to. And
you know, it boosted my confidence
because Darius was being a [__] and
I didn't want to [__] him anymore. And
this dude was on the other guy was on my
for about a year. So I was like, "You
know what? I get some fresh young Let me
fish out this dude." And it was fine. I
had my fun. Who gives a
He was 19. Yeah, he was legal. He was
legal. And I don't give a I genuinely do
not give a She's obviously talking about
ShoeB, yes. She's obviously talking
about ShoeB.
I Okay. She's She's like
going crazy. Here, I'm going to restart
this cuz otherwise, if we
if we don't restart this soon, it's
going to end. And I don't want to get
over on the time section.
>> give a Here we go. We're good. Continue.
>> hot dude
which they do. I I got DMs.
will [__] them. I don't care. Make it
illegal then. Make it illegal. I'm 30
years old, dumb
I was 29 at the time. I'm 30. Ban these
Just get these
about the chat. 30 and 19 is weird.
Yeah, y'all don't be saying that when
you're in the same comments being like,
"Get a fresh 18-year-old girl. They're
virginal." That's what you guys be
saying.
But when I [__] the fresh virgin who's
19, it's a problem cuz I'm a woman.
Yeah, that's the whole point of the
everything they're talking about, yeah.
It's like the whole point. They want men
to be like considered better. That's
like everything they talk about, yeah.
You know that, though.
>> Grown ass man, "Oh, it's different. It's
different." A grown ass man wants a
virgin 18-year-old, it's a Oh, it's
okay. I don't give a about your
standards. I will do whatever the [__] I
want for me. If you don't like it, all
right, do something about it.
Go protest. Start a Zena protest. Keep
Zena away from the fresh 18-year-old men
who want to [__] her. Go do a protest.
I'll come to it.
I'll come to the protest. Go ahead and
do it, [__] I don't give a [__]
Anyway,
moving on from that, yeah. I do my
thing. I don't sit here and virtue
signal and grift. Clearly, I act ratchet
sometimes, a lot of the times. Um I'm a
very free bird. Like, I just do whatever
the [__] I want to do because first of
all, there's no rules to this.
Why the [__] should I police myself
because No Sleep, uh Zinc, uh Who's this
person? Mac 11, uh
Chelsea Billup, names I will never
remember or even pronounce don't like
what I'm doing with my life.
Are you paying my bills? Are you going
to make my life happy for me? Are you
going to help me to reach uh Nirvana?
The [__] Hey, I learned about Nirvana
the other night. We were talking about
Buddhism and some some voice chatters
in.
I didn't really know anything about
Buddhism before that. I don't think Zena
does, either. I feel like Zena knows
nothing about Nirvana.
Are you? Yeah, I'm just reading Trench
Foot Andy groomer. Oh, okay.
Trench Foot Andy said I was a groomer. I
need to go re-evaluate my life because
Trench Foot Andy who probably lives in
his mom's basement, who probably has
on his computer, who's probably
overweight and never even touched a
female with consent other than their
younger sister um
thinks I'm living life wrong.
>> Jesus.
Goodness.
Like Mickey makes sense. I'mma do what
the [__] I want to do.
And you don't have to like it. You
generally don't have to like it. Y'all
mad cuz I
So what? They asked me for it. They
asked me for it and I have messages
where we talk about it.
They asked me for it. Are we're [__]
shaming now because they don't want me
to [__] him in the ass with his own
mold? That's a problem?
That's still Shoe V by the way. That's
still Shoe V. She's just taking shots at
Shoe V.
Poor Shoe V. Poor Shoe V. SOMEBODY CHECK
ON Shoe V. Support for Shoe V is
critical right now.
>> Oh my god, I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry. I
told the world I ate a ass for the first
time because he begged me to give him a
He ate my and then he wanted to So I ate
his ass. I told the world, yeah, I ate
this dude's I don't give a [__]
You should though. That's like someone
else's privacy. It's kind of [__] up.
>> I don't give a [__]
I tried it. Yeah, I tried it. I was in a
relationship with the dude. Yeah, I ate
it, bro.
I did. I certainly did. Will I do it
again? Maybe if I'm in a relationship
again and my dude really wants it and
says, "Yo, I want this." I'm going to do
it. I'm going to do it. Wow.
Where Where is the boy Sam? No, it
wasn't Sam Bon. I didn't even date Sam
Bon. I think we only had sex like three
times. It was very vanilla. Like if Sam
Bon was not a freak. Look, I'mma be
honest, bro. Amy did Myron. Myron, he
can't get mad. I I I owe nobody loyalty
anymore because he lies and lies and
says he has a restraining order which he
does not have because the case was
dismissed and I posted those receipts.
Myron didn't have my back.
Fresh didn't have my back. Chris didn't
have my back. Nobody had my back.
When Tico lies and says the FBI were
after after me, they never were. Like
you can literally go to Miami Dade and
search her name. By yourself, you guys
search my cases all the time. Miami-Dade
Clerk, Amara Samson, you can see it was
literally dismissed because of failure
to appear. Somebody made a account that
said I was going to stab Sneako or some
[__] when I was already dating the
Darius. Like what the
Um anyway, and he had no other evidence
other than a random screenshot that
somebody else made. So, I think the boy
was just embarrassed to be like, "Amy
did him too." And she brought her man
around him. Amy brought her husband
around Myron in front Amy Dangerfield,
Myron. Amy Dangerfield.
>> No. Oh, no. Oh, no. That They are you
[__]
You brought your man around a woman.
>> That woman. That woman. That woman. I
need a I need a fantastic Myron for the
B-word, and I just can't I just keep I
It just comes out, man. I I can't do
anything about it.
>> Oh my god, W gropers. W gropers. W
gropers. W gropers. W gropers. W
gropers. And I can say a lot more. My
ex-husband Myron That's not exposing
Myron. Myron is red-pilled almost every
[__] he puts on the podcast down here.
And he says it. Myron got how many hoes?
You think Myron gives a I don't think
Myron gives a I genuinely don't. Myron's
how many people are on there? And also,
I don't care if he's met my father. He's
not my man. I'm never that man. And I
got proof of that, too. Um yeah, I
respect Myron, but but at the same time,
like did he have my back? Is anybody
defending me when Sneako tries to call
me a liar? No. So, I don't give a [__]
I don't give a [__] about these
that actually are liars, that actually
sit there and lie and grift. I don't
care. I don't care. So, I'm not exposing
a guy that already publicly says he
sleeps with a lot of the women that he
like talks to on the show. Um I mean,
that's literally that's a W for him. He
He likes to do that. Myron, for example,
I respect because Myron out of everybody
in the red pill space, Myron is the only
one that actually lives how he preaches.
In somewhat. In somewhat. Obviously,
they talked about like all the girls,
but even Myron says like he'll still
[__] them recreationally. He does and he
does use them recreationally. He does He
does go out there and you know, slime
these hoes.
Yeah, he never said he was a good
Muslim. Sneako grifts being this Muslim,
but he's still out there doing drugs and
is not married. How you How you been
Muslim for 3 years you still ain't found
a wife? Wasn't the whole point of like
him going on that world tour when it was
a
love speech and he was going on the
world tour it was supposed to find a
place to raise kids and find a wife. Did
he never do that? No, instead he came
the [__] back to America to more on
stream and do drugs over there. That's
it. So.
I don't know. They're all grifters, bro.
They're all grifters.
What happened to that Who was that one
guy who who wore the diaper?
What was his name? Like MLD or something
like that who got exposed as another
Zerk is just a warlock. I kind of I kind
of was about to say Turkey Tom and I
feel bad for that cuz that's like that's
the you know.
I should I shouldn't be saying that
[__]
>> Zerk is not a grifter. Zerk is just
crazy and he's a warlock. The only thing
he grifts is being Catholic. He's a
warlock. Zerk does black magic. I've
always said this and I will always say
it. He does black magic. That's why he
has a great understanding of the occult.
That's why we've always bumped heads
because he does do black magic. Zerk had
a holy Bible with scribblings all over
it and he would put people's name in
shut them into the Bible, okay? There
were pages of the Bible burnt off of it
and folded over with people's names and
writings in it and everything. Ask Heel
Mike. Ask Heel Mike. Zerk does black
[__] magic.
If Sneako was a good Muslim then he
should face the 100 lashing punishment
for sin when not married. Praise Allah.
Exactly.
Exactly. He should just do that. He
should do a stream where he takes the
100 lashes for every Well, I've heard If
you guys don't know her whole thing
about Zerk, she said this about Zerk
like 100 times, right? She has said this
about Zerk like 100 times. So, that's
not a new one for me. That might be new
for you guys, though.
Yeah, that's She talks about Zerk doing
black magic all the time. You know,
being a Muslim.
It'll probably be a couple thousand
lashes, but just do it. Do a stream.
Everybody will watch it and then you'll
be vindicated and then it'll be fine.
But don't sit there and say the matrix
is attacking you. The matrix don't give
a [__] about you. If the matrix isn't
attacking you then I'm the matrix. I am
the matrix because you're a liar. You're
a liar. The old Sneako was cool as [__]
The old Sneako before this grifting
Islam was creative, talented, cool. Like
that Sneako was amazing. This new Sneako
that's grifting all this [__] is insane.
Insane. Like
>> [laughter]
>> I miss the old Sneako. The old Sneako
didn't give a [__]
The old Sneako did not give a [__] The
old Sneako was cool. This Muslim Sneako
is a lie. It's not real. I'm just saying
people talk I'm just talking about the
lies. I don't think Sneako himself is a
bad person.
I don't think he's he's 100% not gay.
People be like, "Oh, he's gay." He was a
model. He's extremely attractive. He's
extremely talented. He is actually very
very very very very smart. Um yeah, like
I said, talented, creative, all of that.
100% give that man his flowers.
But him grifting this Muslim thing, I
guess that was a smart move because he
wanted to go more viral and to get
bigger and he knew that the Islam like
community would carry him.
Yeah, you're not wrong. If he Yes, they
look the they look exactly the same.
Zena should go and find him.
Zena's about to go and find out who Abus
X is, okay? He's going to be very in
She's going to be very into Abus X. But
at the same time, it just ruined a lot
of
>> Sneako Mia Hoffman from Fousey's dating
show. He had Sneako on there. There's a
clip on Twitter of Fousey exposing this.
I got timed out for saying Muslims BTW
soft ass mods girls in person.
Okay, don't talk about Islam. We're not
here to talk about Islam. Don't talk
about Muslims. That's why the mods timed
you out. You have no reason to come in
here and disrespect a religion.
>> Oh, I need to I need to be very careful
about TTS. I think the TTS could be a
problem, all right? I need to be very
careful. You'll be watching.
He's not following. He's not following
what he preaches or
>> Are you still on good terms with
Destiny? Did C tell you to stop talking
to Destiny? Can you expose one more trad
wife?
Well, pick the Anna trad clearly. I
mean, she already got exposed on video.
This is like the kind of thing that Zena
is like a See, Zena's
like obviously By the way, that
shouldn't shock you. Zena's been a
despicable person this entire stream.
We're watching somebody despicable do
despicable things. You can't just get
mad when they do it to somebody that you
care about, right? Obviously, Zena's
been despicable the whole time. She's
been leaking details about people the
whole time. So, if you're going to get
mad about this one, you should have
gotten mad about all the other ones,
too. We just love that the women that
talked about, you know, strippers and
only fans is like, I'm over here like,
"Yeah, I do this. We're here cuz there's
a messy person being a terrible human
being and leaking a bunch of [__] okay?
>> And they need to be talking [__] and
it's like, y'all hoes be so
conservative, but you're the ones you
got to watch out for. At least I'll tell
you who I'm I'll tell you what I'm
doing.
I wear my
You forgot to mention Low Tier God. Bro
said he cracks. Also, any dirt on
Fuentes?
>> yet.
Would I [__] Low Tier God? Um is he
single right now? Yeah, I'll probably
That would be the second black man I I
would consider Yes, I I would [__] Low
Tier God. I think he's hot. I've said
this before. He's a fine ass
Okay? Did I meet him yet? No. If I do
meet him, chances are if the vibes are
right, maybe we do
Okay? I'm telling you right here right
now. Second Yeah, cuz I'm
one black man. Um but anyway,
like I I don't I'm not going to sit here
and and and lie. Like what?
I posted the messages, bro. I've
literally shared the messages.
Why would it be lies? Why Like this is
the thing. Y'all will look at the facts,
y'all will look at the receipts, and you
guys will literally gaslight yourselves
into believing whom like dumb [__]
I will hold two bottles of water in
front of your face and say, these are
two bottles of water, and y'all will
say,
one is probably not even actually water.
One is probably not actually a bottle.
Like is that how stupid you are? Is that
how stupid you are?
Back to what I am saying, yeah, Amy's a
liar, guys.
And I I've just When I first said the
stuff, like when I first tweeted about
the threesome thing, like I don't even
know when that was, like maybe last
year. I got Isn't she married? Yeah, but
this is before she was married. So it is
just it's I think the criticism is that
Amy Dangerfield does like the trad larp
right now,
right? When she's got a very very very
very very not trad past.
And is not was not transparent about it
until quite recently.
>> from people at Fresh and I never met
Convos. What the [__] You're talking
about people I've not even met yet. Like
what? And then you talk about people
that I don't even I don't even
I don't even remember they exist. You
bring up people that I don't remember
even exist. Anyway, I got hit up from
people at Fresh and Fit with her husband
or something like that and we're like,
"Oh,
>> Sneako only went Muslim because of
Andrew Tate going Muslim first. Dude
don't have an original thought in his
peanut brain.
>> Yeah, it was literally because of Andrew
Tate. Yeah. We all know this. He was um
copying everything that Tate did.
Literally. But that's what I was saying.
So you found him cool because he was an
Andrew Tate clone then. That he wasn't
cool or original. She's like, "Sneako is
so awesome like what he was before the
Muslim thing? Cuz cool and original and
great." It's like, "Uh
no. You You literally just described him
as a
an Andrew Tate clone.
So you're not saying that at all.
No. They hit me up and they asked me to
delete the stuff and not expose the Amy
stuff cuz I think they were like
somebody was collabing with the I can't
really remember. I got hit up with one
of their little peoples or whatever. All
right, it was Icey. At the time Icey hit
me up she was like, "Hey, can you delete
this? Amy and and her husband are
together. They got married and they're
working around with Fresh and Fit and
Myron and them and da da da da da
and it's going to start drama." and I
was like,
That's what I said. I'm like, "Girl, I
don't work for them." She talked [__]
about Destiny and then Icey was like,
"I'm just letting you know, you do you."
But yeah, they did try to you know, they
did hit me up talk about I should delete
it.
So
that happened then and I did out of
respect but now I just I don't I just
don't give a [__] about none of these
people who don't support me or help me
with a god damn thing when I'm in a
bind. They're not doing [__] to talk
about help me with out with any [__]
thing. So it's like,
why why do I need to keep showing people
loyalty that ain't loyal to me? That's
that's
that's what I
Um how can anyone have proof of lie when
you literally have proof of messages
that makes no sense. Well, that's what
I'm saying and there's more
conversations at that which I can
literally post on Twitter but it's like,
"Damn, then I'm going to be going in
again." Then it's like, I think I get
tired from all this yapping. Dude, it's
it's good. Listen,
I like Zena's content. Zena
Zena's content is good when she's just
like yapping to a camera solo.
Especially when she's like
letting stuff flow, letting drama
happen, okay?
>> I'm going to do this whole thing
crashing out again and I'm posting all
these videos and receipts again.
Mind you, I have a picture of Sneako
holding the Quran. Literally not 3 days
after he finished out the Amy with me
and he's with Zerkaa. Like, Jesus
Christ. Jesus Christ. These [__] are
fun tea.
These are fun tea.
Also,
which I think Destiny exposed this
before, when
when Destiny's ex-wife Melina was there
and I won the the e-date thing,
he was trying to convince me to get
Melina to have a threesome with us.
And I told Destiny cuz I was like, "Bro,
that's actually crazy." But he was like,
"Actually, I have those messages. I
might as well post those too. I might as
well post them for real." Yeah, why not?
You know what? Zena, go nuts. Go nuts,
Zena. Like, she likes you. She literally
likes you. Um someone made this, me,
Sneako, and another girl that I
convinced to have a threesome with me
and Sneako. Like, y'all forget like, I
mean, then they're like, "Oh my god, you
were Sneako's just laying." These were
adults. These were adults. But yeah, I'm
a hot like all this stuff I'm like me
and my [__]
one of
And I like stuff like I like stuff like
But when you're going to go grift and
then suddenly act like you're this um,
you know,
trad wife and then then start snaking
people, it's like, okay, now we got a
problem cuz you're weird as and you're a
liar. Um and I don't do that. I'm sorry.
You know, listen.
Well, I just want to show you guys
videos from that day, May 17th, you
know, us in the club with Amy. And it's
me and Amy with Sneako the whole time.
Look, I'm making her dance on me. I'm
grabbing her. There's Sneako. There's
Sneako. I am a because he's like There's
Zena getting to work. Getting my [__]
for me. Yeah, because here I am with Amy
right there in the red. It's just messy,
man. I'm grabbing her up. I'm making her
bend over on me. Look, I stood her up. I
made her bend over and twerk on me. And
here's Sneako watching like the He is
like, "Yeah, Zena about to get me some
tonight." And sure sure thing. And then
he got caught. And then Chris caught
him. He's like, "Oh, that's very Muslim
of you." He's like, "No, no, no. No, no,
no. Don't record me. No, no, no. Don't
record me. Don't record me. Don't record
me, Chris." Like, I got it all. And
here's me and Amy getting gay as fun of
Sneako. Y'all forget like I have
everything.
Oh bro, I always have receipts. And
that's the thing. I just hate my mother
Oh my god, me with the twins. No, I
didn't [__] them unfortunately. I would
love to though. I love them.
They're so hot, but no, they weren't
[__] Uh
so I didn't [__] them, but Oh, here we
go again.
Us being gay. Here's Sneako.
I'm [__] them tonight. I'm [__]
them tonight. Yeah, that's a that's your
trad wife for you by the way, getting
all frisky on me in the club. Get the
[__] out of here. These These
Listen, if a [__] is online claiming I
straight up don't understand why Zena's
doing this to Amy.
Like I didn't I have not seen Amy call
her a liar. I saw Sneako call her a liar
or I saw Sneako being like I this isn't
real. This isn't real.
But why why is she just going hard on
Amy?
>> She's a conservative trad wife. Just
know SHE'S NOT.
OH,
I WAIT, I KNOW why she's Oh, right. We
answered that ourselves. No, no, no. She
She either says it directly or she says
it after. It's the the Destiny hip
hippies, right? That Destiny leaked this
about her, that she's doing this cuz
she's close with Destiny. Right.
>> She's not, bro. That These red pill
women are not real. It's literally just
for clicks and views because Right? Cuz
that's the that's where the allegation
comes from is somebody posted a clip.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Destiny said that Amy
Dangerfield Sneako and then it became a
threesome after that, right?
That's where that's where she jumped in.
Unfortunately, a lot of red pill viewers
are like these little virgin griper
incels and they just think, "Oh, a
wholesome conservative woman." And they
are sick. Well, I mean she might have
some other reason. I'm just saying that
makes sense to me cuz she's said She
said in this rant that she really likes
Destiny.
And then it was Destiny who made the
original allegation.
And I just wonder if like that's I I do
feel like she actually talks about that
that hippies. She was like, "You You
want to make a hip piece on my friend?
[__] you." She said that in this. I've
watched it already.
>> sucking for it. They sent for it. And
these women, as you know, we are women.
We are naturally predatorial.
We see them as prey. It is so easy.
That's why I cried on the podcast so
many times because it's so easy to reel
them in in and be like, "Oh yes, I
regret my mistakes on OnlyFans."
Ma'am regrets making a whole bunch of
money.
Stop. It just brings them in like,
"Babe, let me give you money so you can
get out of this. You don't have to do
this." Or the red pill [__] and it's
like, "Oh, I'm so conservative. I'm a
tradwife. I want you to find a good
husband. We need more women like you."
And they get gassed up in the head with
it cuz they like it. That's all it is.
You're just preying on these incel boys
who are
who don't get who sit on the internet
talking [__] about women. Your tears are
real though. Yeah, I'm an actress. I can
literally cry for you right now. Look
how quick. Look at that. There you go.
You see how quick I can cry for you?
Stop playing. Stop playing. I am a
dangerous woman. But the
the only thing about it is I tell you
who I am. Like
You see that? You see that tear? Stop.
I'm not even talking about anything sad
and I got a tear rolling down my cheek
while I'm crinched.
Come on.
I'm I'm actually I Dude, you guys think
I'm emotional right now? I'm totally in
control. Look, I have a tear rolling
down my face. I'm totally in control.
And there's a tear rolling down my
cheek. I'm an actress.
Don't ever say my tears are real, baby,
cuz if it's on the internet, I promise
you I'm doing it for a reason. It's on
purpose. When I'm crying off stream,
those are real. Well, sometimes. Cuz
sometimes I practice crying. But uh
yeah, if I'm showing the internet if I'm
showing the internet
obviously I want the internet to see it.
Are you Are we dumb? Are we dumb? Are we
stupid?
I'm done. I'm done. I'm done. I'm done.
I'm done. I'm done.